And then, oh yeah, that's what I was also going to say, which I forgot to say last time. Ben said, you know, for a math major, Bryce seems to know very little about math. It is true. It was a very bad student. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 46 recorded on October 3rd, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about math, what the Nobel Prize of C++ would be called, and the future of programming language awards. So first of all, what is this?
然后，哦对，这也是我本来要说但上次给忘的事。本说，你知道的，作为一个数学专业的人，布莱斯对数学的了解似乎少得可怜。确实如此。我以前是个很差的学生。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 46 期，录制于 2021 年 10 月 3 日。我是康纳，今天和我一起主持节目的搭档是布莱斯，我们聊了数学、C++ 的诺贝尔奖该叫什么名字，以及编程语言奖项的未来。那么首先，这是什么？
I was, unfortunately, I haven't really been following the twitter thing too much because i was on a 24k run this morning um and then i had to watch the billions episode uh but like jf is is trying to create this can has beard committee first of all anybody that wants to have facial hair, do not let JF or any committee. Y'all do whatever you want. Except for Connor. However you identify. I've seen facial hair on Connor and not that. You do you, including me.
我，不幸的是，我其实并没有太关注推特上的事，因为我今天早上跑了 24 公里，嗯，然后我还得看《亿万》那一集，不过，像杰夫（JF）正在试图建立这个可以留胡子的委员会。首先，任何想要留面部毛发的人，不要让杰夫或任何委员会来管。你们想怎么样就怎么样。除了康纳。不管你怎么认同。我见过康纳留胡子，而那……。做你自己就好，包括我。
I'm allowed to have facial hair too. You have such a baby face. Why would you want to muck that up by putting on a mustache that looks like a 13-year-old crew? It was. Wow. I'm pretty sure. I'm not sure if this podcast has a code of conduct, but if we did, I'm pretty sure you're
我也被允许留面部毛发。你长了一张娃娃脸。你为什么要戴上一个看起来像13岁少年那样的胡子来把事情搞砸呢？确实是。哇。我很确定。我不确定这个播客是否有行为准则，但如果有的话，我很确定你
in violation of that code of conduct, Bryce. No, it looked good. I'm just giving you a rough time. Well, admittedly. Admly admittedly we don't need to backtrack bryce it didn't look good i'm just i'm just trying to make you know a wholesome inclusivity statement you do you don't let other don't let some committee that jf is you know what did he didn't he try and even put himself in charge of the committee or no he tried to put hannah in charge um also to also so uh
违反了行为准则，布莱斯。不，这看起来挺好的。我只是跟你开个玩笑。好吧，诚实地说。坦白说，坦白说，我们不需要倒回去，布莱斯，看起来确实不好看。我只是，我只是想做一个健康的包容性声明，做你自己就好，不要让别人——不要让杰夫所在的某个委员会——你知道吗？他甚至不是想让自己当委员会负责人吗？或者没有？他试图让汉娜当负责人。另外，也是为了——所以，嗯
bryce i don't think listens to the the podcast but i had that strawberry perrier opening the other day didn't go well here we go round two this time we've got a grapefruit buble and it's gonna be magnificent it's gonna i don't i didn't understand like half the words that you just said. And no, I don't listen to podcasts. Here we go. Are you ready? Woo! Except now I'm going to have to silence you because right when I opened it, you started talking. Classic Bryce got in the way of the Grapefruit Buble opening. Yeah.
布莱斯大概不听这个播客，但我那天打开了那个草莓味巴黎水，结果不太好，我们再来一次，这次我们有一罐葡萄柚味的果味气泡水（bubly），这绝对绝妙。这会——我听不懂你刚刚说的那些话的一半。而且，不，我不听播客。我们开始吧。准备好了吗？呜！不过现在我要让你消音了，因为就在我打开它的时候，你开始说话了。典型的布莱斯打断了葡萄柚味气泡水的开启。是啊。
We should probably figure out where Dave is. Yeah, Dave. Don't disappoint me, Dave. I'm fired up to learn it's gonna be great episode gonna be great episode did you listen to episode 45 I sent I sent Bryce a tweet saying that I was super excited because I had forgotten that in the middle of that episode when I started giving a little preview of combinator birds how excited I got when you said that, oh yeah, I'm a big fan of birds. And that might be the single most excited I've been during one of these recordings. And yeah, while we're waiting, while Bryce is getting Dave, feel free to check out my
我们大概应该弄清楚戴夫在哪里。对，戴夫。别让我失望，戴夫。我热血沸腾，这会是一期很棒的节目，会是一期很棒的节目。你听了第 45 期吗？我给布莱斯发了一条推特，说我超级兴奋，因为我忘了在那集节目中间，当我开始稍微预览组合子鸟（combinator birds）的时候，当你听到我说“哦，是的，我是鸟类的超级粉丝”时，你表现得有多兴奋。这可能是我在这些录音过程中感到最兴奋的一次了。好吧，当我们等待的时候，当布莱斯去找戴夫的时候，请随意查看我的
From Retirement talk, Functional Versus Array Programming, which premiered yesterday, October 2nd. Yesterday, for the listener listener is not actually going to be yesterday. It is going to be a week ago. But I'm proud of you. You said the listener. Yeah, I mean, I got to be honest. When I was editing it, it does sound a bit weird. We should have another poll.
关于“退役”（From Retirement）的演讲——函数式与数组编程，该演讲于昨天（即 10 月 2 日）首播。对于听众来说，“昨天”实际上不会是昨天。那将是一周前。不过我为你骄傲。你说了“听众”。对，我的意思是，说实话。当我编辑的时候，听起来确实有点怪。我们应该再做一次民意调查。
Do you, the listener, prefer to be referred to as a collective as the listeners or just as an individual i feel like i've done i've done pretty well on uh on our on our polls so so uh yeah i mean i can get down for a poll so so i'm uh i started on i started unpacking my my programming books today because I have some temporary bookshelves. And I have books two and three of The Art of Computer Programming by Gnu. And you might wonder, well, where's book one? And also, isn't there like a book four? I'm pretty sure there's a book four.
你，也就是听众，作为一个集体，更喜欢被称为“听众们”（listeners），还是仅仅被称为“个体”？我觉得我在我们的民意调查中表现得挺好的，所以，是的，我的意思是，我可以接受一个民意调查。所以，我今天开始整理我的编程书籍了，因为我有几个临时的书架。我有高德纳（Knuth）写的《计算机程序设计艺术》的第二卷和第三卷。你可能会想，第一卷在哪儿？还有，难道不是还有第四卷吗？我很确定有第四卷。
Well, I was given book two and also isn't there like a book four i'm pretty sure there's a book four well i was given book two and three by my uh mentor hartmut and uh i asked him where's the rest of this at and he's like yeah you don't really need them these these two are the important ones wow shots fired hartmut yeah also bring your bring your mic a little bit uh if you did listen to the podcast you'd know that my audio quality is just 10 times or 100 times better than yours and matt gobbelt matt gobbelt and i were chatting about that the other day because we both we both edit our own uh we're the editors behind the podcast so matt has to compliment with ben rady that's his co-host's name, I believe. And yeah. Ooh, look at that.
好吧，我的导师哈特穆特（Hartmut）送了我第二卷和第三卷，然后我问他剩下的都在哪儿，他说，是的，你其实不需要它们，这两本才是最重要的。哇，简直是神补刀，哈特穆特。是的，把你的麦克风拿近一点。如果你听过这个播客，你就会知道我的音频质量比你的好十倍或一百倍。马特·戈贝尔（Matt Gobbett）和我前几天还在聊这个，因为我们俩都自己剪辑，我们是播客背后的剪辑师。所以马特必须和本·拉迪（Ben Rady）搭档，那是他合作主持人的名字，我想是的。是的。哦，看那个。
Now say something. Yeah. See, but now I can't see you. I mean, you can never see me. I'm always in the dark. The other microphone configuration was better when I was recording from my sofa. And also my audio was better when I had a gigantic sofa to soak up all of the noise. Yeah, it's a bit more echoey now.
现在说点什么。对。你看，但现在我看不见你了。我的意思是，你永远看不见我。我总是在黑暗中。当我从沙发上录音时，另一个麦克风配置更好。而且当我有一张巨大的沙发来吸收所有噪音时，我的音频也更好。是的，现在回声多了一点。
Also, too, if you listen to the podcast, I just remembered this. There's a bunch of things that I didn't think we were going to get to talk about today because we had Dave on. But I've started, and you're going to love this, Bryce. I've started to, every once in a while, you go on these tangents that are, you know, one time you'd start talking about your furniture for the second time. I just start speeding you up at 10 times speed um so you'll say oh and so an update on my furniture and uh yeah i'm getting my bed in a month and then we uh it's the best i have i have you know
另外，如果你听这个播客的话，我刚刚想起来。有一堆事情，我原本以为我们今天不会有机会聊到，因为我们邀请了戴夫。但我已经开始——你会喜欢这个的，布莱斯。我开始不时地遇到这样的情况：你总是会扯到一些题外话，比如说，有一回你第二次开始谈论你的家具。我只是开始以 10 倍速快进你的声音，所以你会说：“哦，关于我的家具的最新进展，是的，我一个月后就能拿到我的床了，然后我们——这是最棒的，我有，你知道的……”
you think as the executive producer of this whole thing that you've got the power but no the the person the person yeah of course the person who edits is is always the true that has the true power just like the person that takes the minutes always has the true power um what are the things that i was going to bring up so um yeah we talked about the algebraic groups um after right the day after that we had originally recorded that so i think we recorded it on what September 11th. I talked to Ben Dean for a couple hours on September 12th and he was, he confirmed that indeed a group is what the term that we were looking for,
你以为作为整个节目的执行制片人，你拥有权力，但并没有。那个负责剪辑的人——当然，那个负责剪辑的人总是拥有真正的权力。就像做会议记录的人总是拥有真正的权力一样。嗯，我要提的事情有哪些？哦，对了，我们在最初录制完的那天之后，谈到了代数群。所以我想我们是在 9 月 11 日录制的。我在 9 月 12 日和本·迪恩（Ben Dean）聊了几个小时，他证实了，逆扫描（inverse scans）所需要的那个术语确实是“群”，
for the inverse scans. What do you need? I feel like there was some other stuff though. Oh, there was, there was the, the, our ongoing debate with what's-His-Name from Twitter about whether this operator is associated or not. Oh, yeah. I didn't see your tail end of that, but I sort of— I'm pretty sure he's right now because— I told you, you needed to do a proof.
你需要什么？我觉得还有别的事。哦，对了，还有我们与推特上某某人的持续辩论，关于这个运算符是否具有结合律。哦，是的。我没有看到那件事的尾声，但我有点——我很确定他是对的，因为——我告诉过你，你需要做一个证明。
No, so I agree with him. I think—this is Trolls, Henriksen, right? Yeah, yeah. agree with him i think um uh this is trolls henriksen right yeah yeah i was agreeing with him but i think what he was i think he was misunderstanding that i was agreeing with him and just saying that my code example was wrong and then i i kept on trying to communicate i agree but you could indeed write a overload set that is different from my code example that would work and and i think he he kept there was some there was some miscommunication at some point, but the point that I was saying is that I agree with him.
不，所以我同意他的看法。我想——这是托尔斯·亨里克森（Trolls Henriksen），对吧？对，对。同意他的看法，我想——嗯，这是托尔斯·亨里克森，对吧？对，对。我同意他的看法，但我觉得他——我想他当时误解了我的意思，以为我不同意他，只是说我的代码示例是错的。然后我一直在试图沟通，我同意，但你确实可以编写一个不同于我的代码示例的重载集，并且它能工作。我觉得他一直——在某个时候存在一些沟通不畅，但我要说的是，我同意他的观点。
You just, you needed some fancier overload set than I had in my code example. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. I think I would agree with that. I mean, we had the same thing when we wrote the max consecutive ones where sorting out how to write some of those overloads is a little bit complicated usually a tricky one is is the sort of the aggregating one where you've got you have your intermediate data structure on the left and the right and you have to sort out how to do you have to do some kind of merge thing yeah yeah yeah did we send a did we send a message to to dave yes i did yes but this this episode
你只是需要比我的代码示例更花哨的重载集。哦，对，对，对。我想我同意这一点。我的意思是，当我们编写“最大连续1”的代码时，也有过类似的情况，弄清楚如何编写其中一些重载通常有点复杂。通常比较棘手的一种是聚合那种，你的左边和右边有中间数据结构，你必须弄清楚如何去做——你必须做某种合并之类的东西。是啊，是啊。我们给戴夫发过消息了吗？是的，发了。是的，但这一集
might now become the waiting for dave aberson i mean dave is an important guy and it's sunday morning so i mean also like time zones but yeah there was a couple there was a couple things what did we what did we uh we did the the three parts of 43 44 and 45 were uh i can't remember what 43 well yeah associativity the associativity um requirements and whether yeah having a binary operation with an with overloads does that qualify as associative that was 43 then we did a tangent on should you drop out of school um you can't call it a tangent when the podcast is all tangents uh i mean sometimes we have a goal a destination and then we reach that goal and like the the parts the tangents that we take on the way to that goal are tangents,
现在可能会变成“等待戴夫·阿伯森（Dave Abelson）”。我的意思是，戴夫是个重要人物，而且今天是星期天早上，所以——还有时区问题。但是，是的，有几件事——我们做了第 43、44 和 45 期的三个部分，是——我不记得第 43 期是关于什么的了。哦，对了，结合律——结合律的要求，以及——拥有带重载的二元运算是否符合结合律？那是第 43 期。然后我们扯到了“你应该退学吗”这个话题。当整个播客都是题外话时，你不能称之为题外话。我的意思是，有时候我们有一个目标、一个目的地，然后我们达到了那个目标，就像我们在通往该目标的路上进行的那些题外话是题外话，
but the path itself sometimes, it's probably all tangents. You're correct. And then, yeah, and then the group. Oh, that was the thing I wanted to correct too. I said at one point, oh, it seems like I should learn about set theory. And then Ben Dean accurately or correctly corrected me and said oh that's group theory not set theory and i was like oh yeah fair point um which shows how little i know about math and then oh yeah that's what i was also gonna say which i forgot to say last time i ben said you
但这条路径本身有时，可能全部都是题外话。你说得对。然后，是的，然后是“群”。哦，这也是我想纠正的一点。我曾一度说，哦，我似乎应该学习集合论。然后本·迪恩准确或正确地纠正了我，说“哦，那是群论，不是集合论”。我说，“哦，对，有道理。”这表明我对数学知之甚少。然后，哦对，这也是我本来要说但上次给忘的事。本说，
know for a math major uh bryce seems to know very little about math it is true yeah i thought that was fantastic because at one point too i was like yeah i'm not you know i'm not a pure math guy and you're like well i have a math major and then we still proceeded to not really the the one key thing that i learned in my math education was how to construct a proof. And I still think that that's like the one like useful piece of knowledge that you can, that you really get out of math, a math degree. Yeah, I've been, I've been listening to, what podcast did I listen to the other day day it was one of the more recent lex friedman ones where he had on let me just go find it uh her name was i want to say joanne
你知道的，作为一个数学专业的人，布莱斯对数学的了解似乎少得可怜。确实如此。是的，我觉得这太棒了。因为有一次我也说过，是的，我不是那种纯粹搞数学的人。然后你说，好吧，我可是个数学专业的。然后我们接着还是没有真正——我在数学教育中学到的关键一件事是如何构建证明。我仍然认为那是你可以从数学学位中真正获得的唯一有用的知识。是的，我一直在听——我前几天听的是什么播客？那是最近莱克斯·弗里德曼（Lex Fridman）的节目之一，他在节目中请了——让我去找找。她的名字我想叫乔安妮·
kohler or joe bowler that's actually pretty close j-o and then b-o-a-l-e-r and yeah she is a math educator that's probably like an under understatement of what she does she's probably got a phd and she's a professor somewhere here let's let's go to the episode and get some uh and get some details joe bowler is a professor of mathematics education at stanford and the co-founder of u-cubed whatever that is anyways it was a very interesting conversation it was it was a shorter podcast his are usually like three hours long and this one was only an hour and a half but she was talking about how our podcast that is that is uh the key is 2.2 times speed baby and uh and then that three-hour podcast is only an hour and 20 minutes or something
科勒（Joanne Kohler）或者乔·博勒（Joo Boaler）。其实挺接近的，J-O 然后是 B-O-A-L-E-R。是的，她是一位数学教育家，这大概是对她所做事情的严重轻描淡写，她可能拥有博士学位，并且在某个地方担任教授。来吧，让我们去那一期节目获取一些——获取一些详细信息。乔·博勒是斯坦福大学数学教育教授，也是 u-cubed（不管那是什么）的联合创始人。总之，这是一场非常有趣的对话。这是一期较短的播客，他的节目通常长达三个小时，而这一期只有 一个半小时。但她在谈论我们的播客——这就是关键所在——2.2 倍速播放，宝贝！然后那个三小时的播客只要一个小时 20 分钟左右。
but she was just talking about how like how poorly math is taught and not only how poorly it's taught, but the reputation around math that it's just known as this sort of nerdy thing that a lot of people aren't good at. When really the math that is taught in school, it's a lot of the long form multiplication and long form division and just a bunch of steps and stuff. But there's another kind of math where it's purely visual. long form multiplication and long form division and just a bunch of steps and stuff but like there's another kind of math where it's like you know purely visual and someone won she was talking about how this woman from india basically was told as a kid that you know she was terrible at math when would never be good at it or whatever and then she went on to win the fields medal which is like the nobel prize of mathematics um because she was more of a visual mathematician than she was like a... Anyways.
但她只是在谈论数学是如何被糟糕地教授的，不仅是教得有多糟糕，还有围绕数学的名声——它只被视为一种很多人并不擅长的书呆子气的东西。然而实际上，学校里教的数学，很大一部分是长式乘法、长式除法以及一堆步骤之类的内容。但还有另一种数学，它是纯粹视觉化的。长式乘法、长式除法以及一堆步骤之类的内容，但还有另一种数学，它是——你知道的，纯粹视觉化的。她谈到一个来自印度的女性，基本上从小就被告知她数学极差，永远学不好之类的话，然后她去赢得了菲尔兹奖，这就像是数学界的诺贝尔奖，因为她与其说是一个……不如说她是一个视觉数学家。总之。
If we had a Nobel Prize of C++, what would it be called? Good question. Good question. If we had a Nobel Prize. Well, what is... Is it Nobel and Fields? Are those named after people? Yeah.
如果我们有一个 C++ 的诺贝尔奖，它会叫什么名字？好问题。好问题。如果我们有一个诺贝尔奖。那么，什么是……是诺贝尔和菲尔兹吗？这些都是以人名命名的吗？是的。
It would probably be it'd probably be stepanov right because whoa really well but because let's hope bianna doesn't listen to this podcast no no no no i i because bianna bianna is still active in the community right like like you you have a you have the uh an award or something is named for somebody that's like retired or is no longer no longer involved. And the most prominent C++ person that's no longer involved, I'd argue, is Stepanoff. How does this I'm not going to agree or disagree. I'm just going to ask you a question.
那它大概会叫——大概会叫斯特帕诺夫（Stepanoff）奖吧。因为——哇，真的吗？好吧，但是因为——希望比亚娜（Biyana）没有听这个播客。不，不，不。我——因为比亚娜——比亚娜目前仍然在活跃于社区，对吧？就像你——你有一个——某个奖项是以一个已经退休或不再参与的人的名字命名的。而我可以说，不再参与的最著名的 C++ 人物就是斯特帕诺夫。这怎么——我不会表示同意或反对。我只是问你一个问题。
How does this fit with one time? You told me about your philosophy or view on not like superstar or like pedestalizing people across communities. And you were very anti sort of like, you know, oh, we should all look up to this one person and aspire to be like them. Yeah, yeah. See, that's why it would be a bad idea. But this is why I was going to say, how does this? We constantly talk about bad ideas. How does naming it after a person uh how does that
这怎么符合你曾经说过的一次经历？你曾告诉我你的哲学或观点，即不喜欢在各个社区中把人奉为巨星或把他们高高捧起。你非常反对那种“哦，我们都应该仰望这个人并渴望成为他们”的想法。是啊，是啊。看，这就是为什么这会是个坏主意。但这正是我要说的，这怎么——我们经常讨论糟糕的主意。用一个人的名字命名它——这怎么
what's the word work mesh right right how does that how does it would not you would not do that oh so we're not naming it after a person now that's what i was thinking is we should name it after like uh um the compiler frustration um uh what do they call like uh the awards that they hand out at award ceremonies that you didn't actually win anything they're just recognizing like a lifetime achievement yeah it's like the lifetime achievement of compiler frustration award goes to because you know that like the majority of c++ developers careers and development cycles isn't the majority if it's not the majority it's the plurality uh is spent you know fighting
那个词是什么？行得通吗？对，对。这怎么——你不会那样做。哦，所以我们现在不用人名来命名了？这就是我刚才想的，我们应该用类似于——编译器挫败感——呃，他们把颁奖典礼上颁发的那些你实际上并没有赢得任何东西的奖项叫什么来着？他们只是在表彰终身成就之类的。就像是“编译器挫败感终身成就奖”颁发给……因为你知道，大多数 C++ 开发者的大部分职业生涯和开发周期——如果不是绝大多数，也是相当大一部分——都花在了与编译器搏斗上，
with the compiler and trying to i guess maybe at a certain point if you're louis dion or you know hana dusakova you have you ever you have you know achieved a certain level of what's the word trans you've you've you've transcended and like you have the mystic arts of, like, you know. I don't know. No, I think the more C++ you learn, the weirder your compiler errors become. Yeah. Because, like, it doesn't get better. It just gets worse because then you get to the point where, like, you write code that, like, it's not a compiler error. It's just, like, the compiler, like, fails. not a compile error it's just like the compiler like fails like it gives you an internal compiler error like an ice as they're called you know
试图——我想也许在某个特定的时刻，如果你是路易·迪翁（Louis Dion）或者汉娜·杜沙科娃（Hana Dusakova），你已经——你已经达到了某种程度的——那个词是什么？升华。你已经升华了，并且掌握了诸如……神秘艺术之类的东西。我不知道。不，我觉得你学的 C++ 越多，你的编译器错误就会变得越诡异。对，因为——它不会变好。它只会变得更糟，因为你会到达这样一种境地：你写的代码——这不是一个编译器错误。这只是——编译器直接崩溃了。
where there's like a bug in the compiler and you have to go and diagnose it um yeah internal compiler error yeah ice i like i like the lifetime achievement lifetime achievement in like you know mount template programming or mount something you know yeah yeah yeah i like that all right we'll put it to the listener you know you tell us what the what the lifetime achievement or uh the equivalent of a field or nobel and c++ would be and we'll choose the best one. And also, who should get the first one? Because, of course, Connor and I will now host a black tie award ceremony. Are we going to have the annual? But, like, why would we just do it for C++?
不是编译错误，只是编译器直接崩溃了——它会给你一个内部编译器错误，也就是所谓的 ICE，你知道的，编译器里有个Bug，你得去排查它。嗯，内部编译器错误，对，ICE。我喜欢——我喜欢那个终身成就奖——模板编程终身成就奖，或者某种模板什么的，你知道的。对，对，我喜欢那个。好吧，我们把它交给听众。你知道的，告诉我们，终身成就奖或者 C++ 领域的菲尔兹奖或诺贝尔奖的等价物应该叫什么，我们会选出最好的一个。还有，谁应该获得第一个？因为，当然，康纳和我现在要主持一个黑白领结颁奖典礼。我们要举办年度颁奖典礼吗？但是，等等，为什么我们只为 C++ 举办？
I think we should do it for, oh, my goodness, Bryce, we come up. No, that's, you know, I'm being negative. I've got to tell my ego to be quiet here. But I'm just, I was thinking, and now I'm going to say it. I apologize for the hubris. But that was, that's an amazing idea. We should have the annual, like, programming language awards. It's completely zero guidelines. We just sit here, two cis-het white guys, letting the people know who gets the awards.
我觉得我们应该为——哦天哪，布莱斯，我们想出了一个——不，你知道的，我在消极。我得告诉我的小我（ego）在这里闭嘴。但我只是——我刚才在想，现在我要把它说出来。我为这种傲慢道歉。但那是一个惊人的想法。我们应该举办年度——类似于编程语言奖。完全没有任何指导方针。我们只是坐在这里，两个顺性别异性恋白人男性，让大家知道谁能获奖。
Yeah. We'd have to turn it into some kind of a – maybe we could do it with like a joint, you know, the podcasts come together. Yeah, we should definitely do this. We should definitely do this. I'm going to leave you to make all the arrangements all right yeah i'll try and think of um see this is this is like a perfect example of like what my job currently is like having some random meetings with people kicking around ideas most of them are bad and somebody's like oh we should do that and i'm like all right great go do it make it happen
是的。我们得把它变成某种——也许我们可以联合其他播客一起来做，播客们联合起来。是的，我们绝对应该这么做。我们绝对应该这么做。我把所有的筹划工作都交给你了。好吧，是的，我会试着想想——你看，这就像是一个完美的例子，说明我目前的工作是什么——和一些随机的人开会，抛出各种想法，其中大部分都很糟糕，然后有人说“哦，我们应该那样做”，而我就说“好吧，太棒了，去吧，把它实现”。
yeah i'm already brainstorming i'm just trying to think of how to like the c++ itself get an award or do we just create the thing is is i don't know enough about um other communities but that's the thing is we could just, we'll call it, we'll call the awards explicitly in the title of them, like consciously biased, like completely acknowledging the fact that, you know, I probably only know like a couple of people in the closure community.
是的，我已经在大脑风暴了。我只是在想要怎么做——C++ 本身能得奖吗？还是我们只创造这个东西？问题是，我对其他社区了解不够。但关键在于，我们可以直接在奖项名称中明确指出，比如“有意识的偏见”（consciously biased），完全承认这样一个事实：你知道的，我可能只认识闭包（Closure）社区里的几个人。
So if someone's getting an award in the closure community, it's one of the people that I know. how come this person didn't get the award i didn't know about them so they were not considered due to my lack of awareness of who we could call it the programming language people we like i don't know that's uh i don't think that's explicit enough of like because then it's like do you not do you not like the people that you haven't? And it's like, no. We'll brainstorm.
所以如果有人在闭包社区获奖，那一定是我认识的人之一。怎么这个人没得奖？因为我不知道他，所以由于我缺乏认知，他没有被考虑。我们可以把它叫做“我们喜欢的编程语言人”（The programming language people we like）。我不知道，那——我觉得不够明确，因为那样听起来就像是你——你是不是不喜欢那些你不认识的人？其实不是。我们会集思广益的。
The Twitter, we've got a certain number of listeners now. All we have to do is say tweet at us or open an issue and poof, then we get our answer. It's fantastic. Some bubble in Roman, they had the group. That was great. And then Ben Dean afterwards told me. This is going to be like the listener is watching at least me learn every episode.
推特上现在已经有了一定数量的听众。我们要做的就是让他们在推特上@我们，或者提一个 Issue，然后“砰”，我们就能得到答案。这太棒了。罗马的气泡水，他们有那个群。太棒了。然后本·迪恩事后告诉了我。这感觉就像听众至少在每一集都在看着我学习。
And it's going to be interesting in five or ten years. Yeah. You should teach me some stuff about combinators or something. While we wait for Dave. Is Dave coming? Have we heard from him? I have not heard from Dave. He might be asleep.
而且在五到十年后这会很有趣。是的。在我们等待戴夫的时候，你应该教我一些关于组合子的东西。戴夫要来吗？我们有他的消息吗？我没有戴夫的消息。他可能在睡觉。
Oh, man. Do we want to do like a mini Combinators episode until Dave shows up? If Dave shows up? I think so. Okay, here we go. Oh, boy, oh, boy. Oh, boy, oh, boy. So, thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哦，天哪。在戴夫出现之前，我们要不要做一个迷你的组合子（Combinators）特辑？如果戴夫出现的话？我想是的。好吧，我们开始吧。哦，天哪，哦，天哪。哦，天哪，哦，天哪。那么，感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。